assalamu alaikum peace be with you
welcome to the Dean show and we're doing
chats and cars if you saw coffee and
cars staying on 294 south and I got my
special guest here with us here on the
Dean show shakeout zacardi how are you
doing [ __ ] so now I'll take them I'm
there that's nice to be here I'm the
left all right so we're doing something
a little bit different actually you were
one of the original actually the
original guests on the D show you
remember that I remember it's been at
least I think eight years so what were
we made it had a lot to another month
that now you know Islam based on the
five pillars one accepting that no one's
worthy of worship except the crater the
heavens and earth establishing that
prayer five times a day and then the
fast we've made it what advice do you
have for the millions of people are out
there now who are blessed to reach this
month and wore me down so inshallah the
the advice that I give myself and all of
them is to appreciate the blessings of
Allah in this beautiful month of Ramadan
we take for granted our food our drink
our water we take for granted the easy
lifestyle that we have animal on forces
us to appreciate those blessings forces
us to appreciate how much Allah has
given and how much we take for granted
ramadan is the month of the Quran is the
month of icarus amount of drop it's the
month of prayer it's the month of
community building is the month of going
to the message to this amount of charity
and zakah every single ritual of the
religion of Islam is revived in the
month of Ramadan even Ramona and hedge
because our process them said whoever
does Ramona in the month of Ramadan it
is as if he's done a hedge with me so
even the rewards of a hedge are possible
outside of the days of edge in the month
of Ramadan so no bond is the month of
worship take advantage of each and every
moment during this blessed month tell us
shake how do the news now you have this
this famous athlete that actually now
it's really a trending topic Snoop Doggy
Dogg actually comment on it
commented on it but he was talking about
Akon these are some of the popular names
and we you know you know we kind of we
got to be in tune with what's going on
in the world so he had mentioned how
Akon was actually out there you know
promoting in south africa i believe it
somewhere in those lines solar energy
and other people who were doing a lot of
good he might not have gone it about in
the best way but he had made a comment
that caught some controversy but how can
we know I mean you see that the Dean
show is about promoting purpose out
there really trying to enlighten the
people but what is Islam have to say
about this because you do have people
who will ask you like maybe you know
that they want to accept Islam maybe
they come they've went through this
they're going through it or what does
the somme stance on this basically well
from a 50 perspective even before i get
to the 50 perspective i think from a
spiritual perspective i think one of the
things that we can all benefit from is
that people really need to have a higher
purpose or goal in life and if they
don't have that higher neither purpose
then they're trying to fulfill it in
ways that subhanAllah are just whatever
they want to satisfy every sensual
desire or craving they try to numb out
the senses and the fact of the matter is
when we look around us in the world
today when you don't have a spiritual
purpose when you don't have a higher
goal you just want to stuff yourself
with any other type of goal or you want
to follow every single women desire and
we as Muslims are told there's the
highest gold on the highest desire and
that is the worship of Allah soprano
wadada and I I just want to say and I'm
not speaking about a specific person
because I don't know the person involved
I don't know but I'm saying generally
speaking generally speaking when a
person does have that connection with
Allah then so many of his or her needs
are satisfied and life makes a lot of
sense when you don't have that
connection with Allah then you're lost
you're wandering aimlessly and you don't
know what to do when you're just
experimenting and all types of bizarre
or weird or or fetish or this or that or
just satisfying in every single manner
and unfortunately that's what's going to
happen when you really don't have that
strong connection with your Creator
having said that Islamically from a
filthy perspective
there are definitely those types of
phenomenon where children are born and
their genders are a little bit obscure
they might have you know x XY XY y they
might have a little bit of chromosomes
that are not mainstream or not the
normal chromosomes that are clearly male
or female our classical books that Phil
have discussed this from from you know
they're very beginnings of times and in
such cases to have a surgery to try to
rectify or to try to you know prefer one
gender over the other in such cases that
is completely halal and in fact our
books of have discussed this from the
beginnings of times however mainstream
Sunday law would not allow a person who
is a normal male or a normal female by
that I mean biologically to undergo an
actual operation to change that this is
the mainstream position because this
would be deemed be deemed to be like
challenging the creation of Allah span
without having said that this is our law
our ethics our morals people of other
faiths and civilizations is their
business what they do and it's not ours
to judge them and Allah will be their
judge in the hereafter you know we
obviously as Muslims we really want the
best for all of mankind we have love for
all of mankind and when you see someone
going down and having you like I believe
that many people they play the lotto
you'll see I was at the fruit market the
other day or the supermarket I saw
people standing in line waiting to get
now they actually have vending machines
where you can get the mega mega ball
lotto so I so I see people there
scratching the lotto ticket hoping that
they're going to win it big so do we see
a lot of people turning tour all sorts
of experimentation trying all sorts of
different things because now their heart
now is not connected to the maker of the
heart exactly exactly when you don't
have a higher purpose you try to fill
your life with millions of smaller
purposes and those purposes are never
going to give you that internal
satisfaction there's one of my favorite
quotes of in opium if nope IM says
there's an emptiness in the heart that
is never going to be filled except with
the remembrance of allah and there's a
yearning and desire that's never going
to be satisfied except with connecting
with our loss of hannah wadada that's
what we see around us that people are
thirsting for a reason to live for a
higher goal and purpose
have that and when they don't have it
then anything and everything becomes
legit in the purpose of trying to find
that happiness but guess what they're
not going to find it unless unless and
until they reconnect with their creator
let me ask you a quick question do you
know what the number one capital suicide
site in the world is is it San Francisco
the Golden Gate Bridge that's right
really ok that was just a complete guess
I mean going off what what you were
saying about people now experimenting
how would you maybe you would proceed
because from the outside things look
good like for instance when we think
about Victoria's Secret right the
husband or the wife they go to Victoria
Steve other people you know they know
you know about victoria's secret base
I'm not that innocent so unfortunately
or four actually you know what there's
nothing wrong with Victoria's Secrets
per se we want couples to have a healthy
marriage and whatever allows them to
that um that's good the problems would
come the the objectifying of the woman's
body so publicly otherwise otherwise
there's no problem at all you know with
the lingeries and what stuff that's
being sold if it's done between the
couple's well my point what I wanted to
make was you know the founder you would
think Roy I believe Roy Raymond was his
name if I'm not mistaken you know that
obviously this person was a multi
multi-millionaire he had made it to the
upper on chalant and you know he ended
up jumping off this bridge that I did
not know wow ok interesting so what our
and then we had recently Robin Williams
because many people you would proceed
from the outside that things just look
great things are going great you look at
robin williams always smiling laughing
making people laugh but at the end of
the day people end up committing suicide
over every i believe every 40 seconds
someone in the world is committing
suicide so obviously going back to the
heart not being connected with its maker
rubbing the lotto ticket trying
everything else in the world but you you
just is it is a truth in truly in the
remembrance of God then do hearts find
rest otherwise you just become restless
exactly and what I what I've always
advise especially those people who are
wondering how do I know there's a god I
don't know Islam is true my sincere
advice to them is just get down on your
knees raise your hands up and say oh you
who created me o you who is the creator
of the heavens and
guide me to the way that his best guide
me to the truth don't even say a name
because you're doubting his name you
don't even his existence okay well then
you don't lose anything by reaching out
to him because once he's provided for
you this much he's created you he's
given you all that you need he's not
going to let you go he's not gonna let
you go lost we in Islam we believe
actually a very interesting thing and
that is that anyone who once guidance
will get guidance Allah does not miss
guide the sincere if you truly want to
know the truth then guess what that
sincerity will automatically guide you
to the truth that's a promise that's a
guarantee one hundred percent guarantee
that you're not going to be misguided if
and that's the big if if you want
guidance now tell me you'll say some
some things that quite controversial at
times but a lot of them it just makes
sense because we're used to just doing
things following blind tradition but one
thing I want to ask you about if you
don't mind is like D and you back it up
with evidence that actually the stamens
that you make this that's really amazing
but the film what would you have
something against the film shake do I
have something against though haha yeah
um no I don't have anything against the
foe but my point is that wearing the
throw in and of itself is not what the
Prophet SAW son told us to do so it's
not soon in the sense it's not something
that we are required to do rather the
profit system were the thobe because the
people of his culture and time war
though I mean you guys got to understand
this that you know what at the time of
the process of him even Abu jihad was
wearing a thought and he wasn't
following this window was he know he was
is this Abu jaha wearing what he's
wearing so even opium has a very
profound statement and opium says the
real soon in terms of dress is to follow
the culture of your people because that
is the sunnah of the prophet of the love
weddings
he followed the culture of his people he
didn't invent a new fashion he didn't
design a new dress he didn't come with a
new dress code he followed the culture
of his people so as long as the culture
of your people is in accordance with the
general rules of Islam so your outer is
covered and it's loose and and so the
general rules of Islam as long as
they're followed then you follow the
code of your people and that is why by
the way wherever Islam has gone the
people have had different customs of
dress code the Islam of the Muslims of
Zimbabwe don't dress like the Muslims of
Turkey the Muslims of Turkey don't trust
like the muscles of Indonesia the Muslim
rajasthan don't dress like the Muslims
of Saudi Arabia there's nothing wrong
with that so therefore the Muslims of
America should dress like the people of
America so when you come in when you
come into it to Islam because a lot of
times you you'll see a brother who just
is in University and be like oh he just
accepted Islam and now he's wearing a
big turban on his head the brothers got
him in a thorough no no no IIIi think
this is I mean we appreciate the
zealousness we appreciate the enthusiasm
but this is not something that needs to
be done your Islam is not a measure of
what cloth you're wearing your Islam
really comes about your love of Allah
and you're following what Allah wants
you to follow and in this case the
prophets awesome did not command us to
wear a specific dress code beautiful
beautiful i'm glad you clear that clear
that up that makes a lot of sense
recently in texas did you know i know
you travel to texas part often do is
that true well i'm from texas and assess
i was born there husband i'm a
houstonian these days I'm living in
Tennessee but I'm from Texas reminder I
mean it's very sad in our prayers and do
I go out to the families there was a
couple young lady who I just finished
University she put her head down to go
to sleep and she ended up passing away
and also someone else recently another
Muslim who was also
unexpectedly def had reached them and
it's just a reminder because many of the
youth are out there and many of us we
think that this is something far away
but it's something in reality did you
hear about these these incidents that
just happened recently yes this is the
reality that panel oh you never know
when death will come and it is a las
other than decree alonzo joe says in the
Quran that no one dies unless and until
a las brother has taken into effect and
no one can delay the time of death in
fact in my own extended family as well
there was a recently a very tragedy case
that somebody had just finished his PhD
from America and he went back home you
know to Pakistan and he was celebrating
and everybody was happy and he goes he's
got a headache and he's like 28 29 years
old and he want to go to sleep and
that's it he never woke up and this
shows you I mean somehow that the prime
of his life he came back to try to get
married starting a new life you know
just finished a PhD in engineering I
mean this is like amazing right so happy
everybody but then Subhan Allah trip
home and that's it so what that shows us
is that every one of us needs to be
prepared for that day before it comes
because we don't know when it's going to
come it's not something that we're
preparing for is not something we're
thinking about but it's going to happen
unexpectedly and when it happens we had
better be prepared for it we're gonna go
ahead and take a break we're here doing
something new with shakeout so cardi
Ramadan we'll be right back gotta pay a
toll and Islamic please subscribe to the
dvo follow us on our official Facebook
and Twitter pages in the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below that
kind of Dean show I hope everybody's
having a wonderful Ramadan we got to
stay consistent hamdullah we're going in
2016 almost reaching 500 episodes we got
one of the original guests you know we
were putting on a hijab and we did those
exciting q and A's that was with our
Sheikh right here yasser carly shay
against the car doctors say gasps
mccarthy tell us we always try to now
clear up the many misconceptions and we
start to get one step forward and then
some crazy lunatics something gets
associated misrepresented in the media
or the media keeps showing this this
group Isis as if they represent Islam
what is your take on this you've done a
lot
talks on this topic yeah so my point is
that Isis is not coming from the
tradition of Islam the emergence of Isis
actually has to do with the failure of
American foreign policy that the entire
destabilization of the country having
invaded Iraq having put sanctions on it
for 13 years having destroyed the entire
infrastructure the civil society of the
country is completely demolished and on
top of that a civil war almost began
between the Shiites and Sunnis you know
throughout the two thousand six seven
eight nine all of this led to the
complete chaos the the the
destabilization of the region and from
that chaos emerged a group that tried to
bring its own version of stability if
you were to remove all of that
destabilization all that chaos and all
that failed Wars and whatnot you would
not have had right Isis so what I tell
you know the people here in America is
that Isis is not coming from the Quran
Isis was coming from a failure of
political you know foreign policies in
the region and that's why Isis is such a
unique phenomenon that in the history of
Islam we've never seen people like this
going and beheading people you know
putting them on videotape and I mean
this is so backward burning a person
alive I mean and killing Shiites left
right and center I mean you know i'm a
sunni i don't agree with GI theology
right i'm not going to promote she
ideology but at the same time you're
going to just go kill and Massacre them
is that what islam teaches you I mean
you want to have a dialogue have a doll
you want to debate have a debate but
just going and killing somebody just
because they're Shiite which Khalifa a
neuroma has ever done this 20 may yes
they abbasid the Ottomans who has ever
just gone and killed killed killed so
the fact of the matter is that this is
something that we have clear evidences
from the horn on asuna to demonstrate
that these people have crossed the red
line too many times and we have we and
we're refuting them left right and
center but the fact of the matter is as
I said we need to understand and
contextualize where they're coming from
they're not coming from the Quran
they're coming from a complete failure
of the political infrastructure of the
region primarily the cause of that
failure is in fact our own country that
is America and its own growth and
competencies in that region what about
what are your thoughts on when you see
the media constantly focusing on this
fridge and look element Deborah's I
represents maybe point zero zero one
nine percent of Muslims Muslims being
one point six seven billion in the world
but when you see for instance
individuals planting day it was on the
news not too long ago and wanting to set
up Muslims by planting what was called
they called a Koran bomb and then
recently this Christian minister this
Chris Christian minister who was
plotting basically to go ahead and
massacre a whole town of Muslims did you
hear about the shape yeah i saw this
that there was this christian guy
wanting to actually you know plant some
bombs and he actually had bombs in his
car and his news was hardly ever heard
on the mainstream we just didn't even
hear a bleep and yet when a muslim does
something obviously we know the double
standards is so sad that muslim does
something whether successful
unsuccessfully becomes front you know
page news recently it was it today or
yesterday somebody in dallas attacked
the police station and wanted to kill
them and whatnot we don't even know his
religion to this day his religion did
you even come into it where is he coming
from what's his you know he's just a
white Caucasian guy who wanted to kill
some policeman he went and attacked the
police station and not nothing is known
about which church he would go to his
church isn't being brought into it you
know so it's definitely something we
need to just be cognizant of the reality
is unfortunately there does seem to be
some type of double standards in this
regard and our job is to continue to
point those double standards out for the
not yet Muslims who are tuning in
watching the dean show sheikh tell us in
brief someone really likes to they like
the clean simple message of islam the
pure monotheism connecting with the
crater doing good living a good life
they hear all these this misinformation
out there you mentioned earlier to
really get get out get down to call upon
God alone what advice do you give for
that person we talked about definitely
touched upon it can come at any time we
touched about Isis you know just what
would you leave him with this blessed
month of Ramadan for the people were out
there we actually I even know somebody
who's been watching addy show and that
person's actually wants to learn how
he's going too fast this month actually
but he's still not ready to accept Islam
people like this or out there they're
just seeking searching the heart is
empty there scratching a lot of tickets
you know they're wanting to try this and
that but to save them a loss of time
going into law the wrong direction what
advice do you give my ID my advice for
them is that first and foremost raise
your hands up and ask the one who
created you you have to have that desire
from within secondly don't believe the
media and the hype go and speak to a
Muslim go and visit a message it go and
see for yourself really what what Islam
is about and then the final point of
advice is realize that the ultimate
question that you need to ask yourself
is who created me and why did he do that
that's the ultimate question who is my
creator and what am I doing here and i
would say that no other religion or
philosophy or system has the simplest
and the most logical and the most
rational answer and that is that the one
perfect being created me and we are here
in order that we can venerate and praise
Him and venerating and praising him and
worshipping Him entails many things of
them is to be good and kind and loving
to other human beings and of them is to
worship him and praise Him and that
means some rituals and prayers and
that's like the fast of Ramadan that
these are all aspects these are all
elements of worshipping the one true God
so the three points number one pray to
Him number to visit your own local
mosque or your own local community visit
Muslims and number three think think
think think about the purpose of life
and what you're doing here and if you
have those three insha'Allah God willing
you will find the answer last question
here with Sheikh dr. yasir qadhi for
those who have consciously they made a
decision that Islam is a truth based on
proof and evidence they really want to
get to Jenna they have an opportunity to
during this month of Ramadan what advice
do you have for them it can be really
challenging and tough out there
everything is calling you dunya is
opening up to you but now they made it
to an
Ramadan what advice do you have before
we conclude don't delay because you
don't know how many other Ramadan's you
have left do not delay if you know it's
the truth if you know made up your
decision you made up your mind then put
your trust and the one who created you
bismillah say in the name of Allah and
that's it go for it Sheikh thank you
very much did you enjoy this nice little
car ride with us I enjoyed it immensely
was a very unique unique idea and I hope
inshallah we can do it again thank you
very much she's not go hider thank you
all thank you all for tuning in to the
disha once again consistency that's
really important we try to stay
consistent going on almost 10 years
since 2006 almost reaching 500 episodes
here with one of the original guests
enjoy your Madonna have a blessed
Ramadan and make it a way of life so we
can continue to benefit we can go from
all of this beautiful this gift that the
Creator has given us of Islam subscribe
if you haven't already to the Dean shall
continue to tune in call us if you have
any questions 1 866 to Islam we'll see
you next time until then please please
please subscribe to the dvo follow us on
our official Facebook and Twitter pages
in the links below please also help
support the V show by making a donation
in the link below